we're seeing a martial law
is this a new character i've never seen
double music is this a new character
that's crazy
i don't know man i'm pretty sure you got
some good ass tekken t-shirts with that
martial law hope you guys can check that
out but we see martial law versus kazuya
a legacy matchup if you would
early start for casey finds the wall
breaks the balcony and we see him just
play his dominance here
but this is double's go-to character
this is the one he gets yeah this is his
um his go-to this is his yeah his one
bay so now we see him
push towards the wall oh he breaks it
continues the combo
oh he went he's a madman
you see that yeah
is swinging and swinging big oh
speaking of swinging bait he was ready
for that electric whip punish there with
that while standing too that was nuts
good stuff there double taking that
first round
yeah and back and forth they go right
casey is very much in this match finds
the electric we're seeing a lot more
aggression a lot more offense coming out
of k-skate not that real measured
approach now in the early seconds splats
him against the wall once again
oh my goodness look at all this damage
and all that from one sequence so far
let's see what cakes is able to do here
and if double is able to come back
because he does have rage there's the
first slidey
oh magic four to the wall thankfully
that mitigated the damage okay jess goes
for a hell sweep was that tip range and
now just goes for the down four back and
forth they go mark man
here we go the follow-up here
let's see how he's able to really break
him down because right now oh my god he
got him going for the dragon slide
motion and he hit him with the electric
out of it well he messed the compo
this is interesting oh
yeah gonna punch the somersault there
keeping him at bay here now we see ksk
wow what a win punish there
he gets the third round
interesting sequence from both of the
players uh they're definitely playing
with some type of nerves here i don't
know what it was but they definitely had
a moment where they were both like i
don't know what's going on mom's
spaghetti oh here we go
i never freeze but in this high level
you will have those type of moments
ladies and gentlemen but double shaking
with the cobwebs wow ksk fighting his
way out of that wall with a hell sweep
now we're at center
nice oh he'd go for the slide i thought
he was going to go for it oh he's dead
wow and if that was ever okay
i was gonna say if there's ever a sign
there you're gonna have to switch up the
character that might have been it
because at the very end you know even
though it comes down to how you deal
with the offense from kazuya i feel like
had he another character whether it was
fakamrum or even lydia he might have
been more well equipped to kind of deal
with that offense
true and it just shows that you know
what the legacy match up uh casey was
ready for that law he was he was so good
at um just sniping out those options and
just really imploring his offense and um
yeah i think double now really has to
consider picking a different character
as much as i love the martial as much as
i love that shirt mark man i think
double considering uh changing up that
character
yeah which sucks duke is like you know
he's he's his main is is love right but
i feel like uh
sometimes the game develops in a way
where you have to you're forced to kind
of try other characters out and you know
obviously he tried with law here and he
did okay at the start of the match but
he fell into the vortex man when
when casey flips that switch sometimes
all you can do is watch and and that's
what we saw a lot towards the end of the
match
mm-hmm poetry in motion but for the one
facing quesque it's to their expense
so he will have to adjust maybe yeah he
might consider the lydia or the fakamram
either way um that can put kck off a
loop going with a lydia no and we're
going to twilight conflict this seems to
be the stage of the day markman
yeah i i'm actually curious to see this
because i know doubles style the way
that he's been played we haven't
necessarily seen it when he used lydia
earlier when he was facing off against
again but i've seen him play in other
matchups he makes good use of the
political storm and this might be a
specific character matchup where he can
actually utilize that it's not like he's
fighting against the big tree trunk legs
of bakula this
methodical approach and how he's going
to go into the matchup
followed up and finally found the wall
oh the heaven and earth low
okay now casey has rage but look at the
life he's done okay
gets the mid maybe he and now goes what
is the driver
you just want maybe he wants a mid
electric that's all he wants
let's see how it goes it
i wasn't able to bring it out but
excellent start for double yeah
oh yeah
okay escape playing a little more
methodical now as you mentioned uh
double might want to be able to be the
one to push for the offense and try to
open him up you see he is chilling
waiting for his openings but wow the
range on that rising too
it's like it's like he's used to using
while standing too for some reason
it's like he's used to it oh my goodness
not sure why from a lydia maine okay
now two rounds straight yeah this this
lydia pick has been paying off so far
for double but you know what quesadilla
as we've seen in the previous matches
can be a slow starter for matchups he's
not really comfortable with so oh my god
low parry
here we go there's going to be a lot of
damage
last hit delayed of course
how is he going to deal with this here
oh
found the wall
oh my gosh all right kck starting to
build up some momentum but the red tape
just there to stop him it's the wall
splat double oh get the low block case k
gonna make this one count
great stuff there hitting that glorious
demon god fist follow up into the combo
into the rage art finally getting around
here against doubles lydia
let's see if that momentum will help him
carry and maybe even up the rounds
he's still a tall tower oh my god
it's so crazy
yeah
i can't believe that hit found his
ankles anyway yeah that's that's one of
the moves go to but then there's that
political storm you were talking about
another lowberry
nice delay there
oh this is big it's the wall splat
and he's going to go downstairs found
the balcony
oh he missed it no off axis oh he's
putting on the blender oh my god the
rage drive from lydia and now breaks the
balcony double taking the round and the
match
pretty well what a piece
yeah lydia is a good character i think a
lot of people have been talking about it
recently but obviously it works out for
double in his play style it gives them
more tools in the match-up as well and i
think one of the things that we saw is i
guess maybe the fear of lydia getting up
close and how casey reacts to it and it
obviously worked out in in double's
favor because you know he started
getting certain things like the while
standing one string he started getting
the wall standing fours and then
we really haven't seen him use too many
of her tools we have we haven't seen the
hop kick we saw obviously the wall
setting too during certain situations
but uh i think that that's been key so
far but
again i feel like you can't count out uh
case scanners because you because again
all it takes yeah is one health sweep
and to that'll start everything
uh a series on that unfortunate events
that's true
then that sequence i mean that snowball
can turn into a landslide easily with
with how cascade managed to get himself
out of that situation with kuzen and
yeah you know he can never count him out
even though double i would say yeah he
was able to win that
in sort yeah dominant fashion but still
kck was showing showing some signs of
life showing some moments of brilliance
there and you can also make the same
case for double he did not show the full
tool kit of lydia not much hop kicks i
think there was like one down back two
that was hit we did see some rising twos
there but we haven't seen like how we we
see like high-level lydia's like again
use lydia just yet so still a lot for
these two players to showcase in this
matchup and it's still pretty evened up
so double versus case gay only one can
move on to the losers semi-finals who
will it be and where are we going
devil's pit
oh man home field advantage and you know
he's recognized it he had good luck
early on as he played on the stage and
we're going back again let's see how
this one
plays out
devil's been a very unique stage the
only one of the only stages in the game
where where it's the potential final
round it goes into an open area
fight
and we saw that he can deal well in open
areas but now who's gonna take advantage
of these walls nice punish from double
followed up peppered it with a little
low there you know cascade being very
measured with his approach doesn't want
to get caught with anything big from
lydia
oh nice side step pop
that was great stuff and he's gonna get
the wall this time too
yikes big damage try to go for the side
step four but caught him with the mid
and now double yep he's all warmed up
with this lydia
all right he caught him with the wheel
kick the follow-up here let's see what
he does
oh we caught him out of the air
fast thinking on casey's side oh they
trade in favor of case k and just like
that not even 15 seconds was able to get
that second round
i mean it was pretty much a perfect
other than i trade
casey doing a great job of really
controlling the offense off the okuzami
but going back the other way here comes
double
oh
yo
good punish there
oh moving away and now cascade
trying to capitalize on that wall
situation but double looking pretty
healthy running one
perfect oh
yeah so now find a potential uh uh set
point for a set round for a double
oh yeah let's see what he does
kck
needs this round to stay alive of course
get some with the big bop the follow up
with the steel pedal and the stature
kick
nice
well rising twin pistons there now
double in the life deficit
constantly ducking he does not want to
deal with those electrics or lows oh my
god speaking of electrics
that one lands final final round markman
oh yeah here we go
could be anybody's match both of these
players have been doing very very well
but again it all comes down to this you
have to put all your cards on the table
oh and a big block
yeah kck was yeah betting it all in the
well bet the first few seconds of that
round without low but now double
trying to still maintain the lead here
another blocked health he knew
he knew that he was gonna go for the
hell sweep after that particular
situation that's some advanced stuff
there you gotta think
about it is oh there he's gonna go keep
going for the hell sweep watch out get
the big bop follow up with the steel
pedal oh my god man he's building
something up okay no no more rage
oh wow
yeah i was at the edge of my seat that
one how many hell sweeps did casey throw
out but double yeah block most of them
double moving on unfortunately that's
the end of the run for k-skate but man
i'm sure he's gained a lot of fans here
at the tekken online challenge japan
masters
double is so dirty he
whiffed